there's this horrifying video on the web
of you're in the water Jason Biggs is
standing on what appears to be a doc and
he's there's no other way to say it he's
urinating on you and I had to bring it
up because I think we need an
explanation of what happened how this
happened the tone in your voice
indicates that I was a party to this or
something that I requested to be
happening or to happen to me I did not
want to be urinated on that's not
something I was trying to get to happen
it did happen and I'm still here I was
offered a story well what does Jason
Biggs why is he doing this he's got
problems okay and he had a urinary tract
infection on this trip and no he did it
but so I got off the boat there's like a
little blood like a LoJack they call it
you know the little thing off of a boat
I don't know if everybody knows what
that is I'm not even sure I do so I
jumped off of it and the tide was very
strong so I was holding on to it because
we were getting in another boat to go to
the beach so I was holding on to the
boat the only place for me to go would
be under the vessel that we were in all
of a sudden I realized I looked up and
Jason's penis was there and he was
urinating on my face and I thought it
was so funny that somebody would pee on
someone's face that I was laughing so
hard I couldn't swim away
and even if I could have swam I would
have just swam right into the boat so I
was trapped
I won't in a hurry Bermuda trying
this is an awful thing he's doing why
are doing that listen I can take one for
the team if somebody needs to get
urinated on I am a happy to do that I
don't care about your inner one who
gives a [ __ ] sorry
who cares I mean who cares ocean you
know many disgusting things are living
the ocean that's like a human toilet
then you're okay with be having urine
get on you listen it's not something I
seek out but if somebody's gonna if
there are three of us here and somebody
is gonna get urinated on I'll do it I'll
do it
[Applause]
friends of yours could say that for you
absolutely not I don't have any friends
that are like by the way if you ever
need to urinate on me I'm the one you
can also look at it to it's it's
flattering that he felt that comfort
level with you yeah you know that is
flattering yeah yeah he's like I think
it's gonna be okay if I pee on her head
right now he assumed that would be fine
and it was and also another thing is
people like oh that's so disgusting it's
so disgusting it's like yeah it is
disgusting but there are things that are
way more disgusting than that so I mean
I don't think it's [ __ ] to me it's
funny that somebody could be that rude
to another person and so that made me
really happy okay there's something more
discussing that the ocean the ocean is
at all kinds of fish don't take the
ocean over someone do it uh especially
big so god no hole turn in yeah oceans
are called Ribisi their eggs go to the
bathroom
this is the most depressing underwater
documentary I've ever heard are you do
you go in the water of the ocean Ilan
are you because some people hate those I
like the ocean you I do I like the ocean
very much yeah you must do you float a
lot in the ocean
sure what do you think it might be that
cast iron heart
[Applause]
you